Hi everyone, it's Caitlin Luna, host of Speaking of Psychology. This episode was recorded live during APA 2019, our annual convention that was held in Chicago this year. I was away on maternity leave during that time, so my colleague Dr. Vale Wright was a guest host. We hope you enjoy the episode. Hello, and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm Dr. Vale Wright, the director of research and special projects at APA. And I'm guest hosting this podcast from APA 2019 here in Chicago. Joining us today is Dr. Angela Lawson.
大家好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本期节目是在我们今年于芝加哥举办的年度大会——2019年美国心理学会（APA）大会期间现场录制的。当时我正在休产假，所以由我的同事瓦尔·赖特（Vale Wright）博士担任客座主持人。希望大家喜欢这期节目。大家好，欢迎收听美国心理学会的播客《心理学谈话》。我是瓦尔·赖特博士，美国心理学会研究与特别项目主任。我正在芝加哥的2019年美国心理学会大会上主持这期播客。今天来到我们节目的是安吉拉·劳森（Angela Lawson）博士。
She's the associate professor in the departments of obstetrics in gynecology at Northwestern University here in Chicago. And today we're going to be talking about infertility. About one in eight U.S. women aged 15 to 44 have problems conceiving. And women who experience infertility reported as one of the most difficult experiences of their life. So I'm really excited to have Dr. Lawson here. to help us separate back from fiction, to help us debunk some of the myths that exist about infertility and really open up a dialogue about an uncomfortable and kind of challenging topic. So thank you. Welcome, Dr. Lawson. Thank you. And full disclosure for all listeners,
她是芝加哥西北大学妇产科的副教授。今天我们要讨论的是不孕不育。在美国，15岁到44岁的女性中，大约每八个人里就有一个在受孕方面存在困难。而经历过不孕不育的女性表示，这是她们一生中最艰难的经历之一。所以我很高兴能请到劳森博士，帮助我们去伪存真，打破关于不孕不育的种种迷思，并就这个令人不适且充满挑战的话题展开对话。谢谢你，欢迎劳森博士。谢谢。顺便向所有听众说明一下，
Dr. Lawson and all your friends. We went to graduate school together. We were in the same research lab, and we've been best friends for about 17 years. Correct. So we're going to refer to each other by our first names. because otherwise it gets a little weird. So in that vein, you know, Angela, like I mentioned, we both were in the same research lab. The research lab was really focused on harassment and discrimination in the workplace. We both still do a little bit of that work, but we've gone pretty different ways. I work for APA.
劳森博士和各位朋友，我们曾一起读研究生。我们在同一个研究实验室工作，并且已经做了大约17年的好朋友。没错。所以我们要直呼对方的名字，否则会觉得有点奇怪。顺便说一下，安吉拉，正如我提到的，我们俩曾在同一个研究实验室。那个实验室主要关注职场骚扰和歧视问题。我们现在都还在做一点相关工作，但我们已经走上了截然不同的道路。我在美国心理学会工作，
I'm guest hosting a podcast right now, and you're working in infertility. So maybe we could start by you kind of talking about how you got here and, you know, why you're here. Certainly. And thank you for having me here today. We did start in the same research lab. We had a pretty heavy focus on the experiences of trauma in women's daily lives. And so it surprised me, too, to wind up in the Department of OBGYN at Northwestern in a fertility clinic. And really, the way that I wound up there is kind of a happy accident.
我现在在客座主持播客，而你从事的是不孕不育领域的工作。所以，也许我们可以从你如何走到今天，以及你为什么会在这里开始聊起。当然。谢谢你今天邀请我。我们确实是在同一个研究实验室起步的。我们当时非常关注女性日常生活中创伤的经历。所以，最终我会在西北大学的生育诊所妇产科工作，这让我自己也很惊讶。其实，我能到那里工作纯属一个美丽的意外。
It didn't seem happy initially. So when I finished my fellowship year, it was 2008. and the economy had just crashed. And there were no jobs that were available related to trauma and women's experiences of trauma. And so I was scrambling. And I ended up reaching out to various OBGYN practices, academic medicine practices, thinking that at least I'll still be able to work with women. And given that unfortunately, women have a significant risk of experiencing some type of trauma
起初这看起来并不美好。当我完成博士后研究的那一年是2008年，当时经济刚刚崩溃。没有任何与创伤及女性创伤经历相关的工作机会。所以我当时很慌乱。我最终联系了各种妇产科诊所和学术医疗机构，心想至少我还能继续为女性服务。鉴于不幸的是，女性在生活中经历某种创伤的风险很高，
in their life, maybe I could still do a similar line of work. and I ended up getting hired in the fertility clinic. And very quickly, what I realized is how much trauma is involved in fertility and reproduction and reproductive loss. And so while I initially wasn't sure if it was going to be the best fit for me, I've fallen in love with the field and I can't imagine myself doing anything different. It's really funny how these happy accidents happen, that if you just sort of follow where life takes you, that sometimes you end up in a place that you didn't think was possible.
也许我还能从事类似的工作。最终我被生育诊所录用了。我很快意识到，生育、生殖以及生殖损失中涉及了多少创伤。虽然起初我不确定这是否最适合我，但我已经爱上了这个领域，无法想象自己做其他任何工作。这些美丽的意外发生时真的很奇妙，如果你只是顺其自然，有时你会到达一个你认为不可能到达的地方。
And I think for one thing, I don't think most people associate psychologists with fertility. So what does a psychologist do in a fertility clinic? So there's actually three psychologists in the fertility clinic at Northwestern. And it's an academic medicine practice. And so it's a mix of clinical work and academic work teaching and research. The clinical work that we do, patients who are experiencing infertility, as you mentioned, experience a lot of psychological distress. And so patients who are going to be pursuing
我认为有一点是，大多数人可能不会把心理学家和生育联系在一起。那么，心理学家在生育诊所里做什么呢？西北大学生育诊所里其实有三位心理学家。这是一家学术医疗机构，所以工作内容是临床工作、学术教学和研究的结合。我们所做的临床工作是，正如你提到的，经历不孕不育的患者会承受巨大的心理压力。因此，那些即将进行
the more complex types of fertility treatment, like in vitro fertilization or use of donor egg or donor sperm or gestational carriers, also women who are going to freeze their eggs or are transgender patients who are going to freeze their eggs actually meet with one of the psychologists before they begin their treatment to try and prepare them to cope to get the support systems in place that they might need,
更复杂生育治疗的患者，比如体外受精（IVF）、使用捐赠卵子或精子，或者代孕，还有那些准备冷冻卵子的女性，或者是准备冷冻卵子的跨性别患者，在开始治疗前都会先见一位心理学家，试图帮助她们做好应对准备，建立她们可能需要的支持系统，
to be able to get through treatment from an emotional place that is best for them. Right. And I would think, you know, often we think of fertility and infertility is just a woman's issue, but it's really not, right? I mean, we're talking about more than just what women are going through. That's exactly right. So the diagnosis of infertility, it is more common that you have both a male and female factor diagnosis than it to just be a female factor diagnosis. And there's a significant... So that means that it's not just the woman that's infertile, but actually that both individuals and the couple are having problems.
以便她们能以最佳的情绪状态度过治疗过程。没错。我想，我们通常认为生育和不孕不育只是女性的问题，但事实并非如此，对吧？我的意思是，我们讨论的不仅仅是女性正在经历的事情。完全正确。所以，不孕不育的诊断中，男女双方因素共同导致的诊断比单纯女性因素导致的诊断更为常见。而且有一个重要的……这意味着不孕不育的不仅仅是女性，实际上是个人和夫妻双方都存在问题。
Absolutely. It is very rarely one person's fault, so to speak, and I hate using that word, but we have a number of patients that have male factor fertility concerns, that have female factor fertility concerns, but sperm and eggs are equally important. And usually when something's not working, it's a product of those sperm and eggs, not the woman, and it's her fault, and she's done something wrong. You know, and I was reading a study recently that I talked about who seeks out fertility treatments. And it seems to be that it's often white women with higher economic status that really seem to be seeking out these treatments. But they can't possibly be the only ones with fertility issues. So what are we doing about that? What's your take? So there's a lot of
绝对是这样。很少是某一个人的“错”，我讨厌用这个词，但我们有很多患者存在男性因素的生育问题，也有女性因素的生育问题，但精子和卵子同样重要。通常当事情进展不顺时，这是精子和卵子共同的结果，而不是女性的错，也不是她做错了什么。你知道，我最近读到一项研究，讨论的是谁在寻求生育治疗。看起来通常是经济地位较高的白人女性在寻求这些治疗。但她们不可能仅仅是唯一有生育问题的人群。我们对此做了什么？你的看法是什么？所以有很多
reasons why we're seeing that. They're all unfortunate. So in Illinois, Illinois is one of the few states that has a fertility mandate, meaning that within certain limits, your insurer in Illinois, if you have an Illinois-based employer, is going to provide you in all likelihood with coverage, medical coverage for fertility treatment. But there's only, I believe, 16 states currently that have that mandate. And so if you don't have that mandate or you don't have the coverage for fertility treatment, you're probably not going to be able to pay for it. Because fertility treatment can be rather expensive if you're paying out of pocket. So that's one of the reasons that limits some of the patients that we have. Do you have like a ballpark? Like sort of what are the costs?
原因导致了这种现象。它们都很不幸。在伊利诺伊州，它是少数几个有生育强制保险法的州之一，这意味着在一定限度内，如果你在伊利诺伊州有雇主，你的保险公司很可能会为你提供生育治疗的医疗保险。但据我所知，目前只有16个州有这项强制规定。所以如果你所在的州没有这项规定，或者你没有生育治疗的保险，你可能就无法支付费用。因为如果你自费的话，生育治疗可能会非常昂贵。这就是限制我们部分患者的原因之一。你有一个大概的数字吗？比如费用是多少？
So it depends on the type of treatment, but IVF is the one that most people talk about. If you're paying for IVF out of pocket, the medical procedures by themselves without medication are going to be around $10,000 per try. And then the medications on top of that can be as much as $5,000 $8,000. Wow. So it's a lot of money to pay out of pocket. If you don't have the insurance coverage, you're probably not going to be able to do it. We see a lot of a lot of couples starting GoFundMe's, any way that they can get funding to support. There's actually a lot of grants out there for patients who can't afford treatment to be able to apply. But even with that, there's just a lot of patients who can't afford it.
这取决于治疗类型，但体外受精（IVF）是大多数人谈论的。如果你自费进行IVF，单次医疗程序（不含药物）大约需要1万美元。再加上药物费用，可能高达5000到8000美元。哇。所以自费需要支付一大笔钱。如果你没有保险，你可能就无法进行治疗。我们看到很多夫妻发起众筹，想尽一切办法筹集资金。其实有很多针对负担不起治疗费用的患者的资助项目可以申请。但即便如此，还是有很多患者负担不起。
But that really doesn't explain all of why patients are fairly similar in terms of socioeconomic background that come to a clinic. You know, we live in a mandated state, and yet we still tend to see primarily how, higher SES, higher educated white women and their partners coming in for fertility treatment. Why are we not seeing other patients with diverse backgrounds? And there's a lot of history that goes into that, too. I think, you know, unfortunately, the medical system in OBGYN and particularly has a fairly dark past, where women who were not white, who did not have money, who did not have the same education, underwent treatments that were harmful in many ways.
但这并不能完全解释为什么来诊所的患者在社会经济背景上如此相似。你知道，我们生活在一个有强制保险的州，但我们仍然倾向于看到主要是高社会经济地位、受过高等教育的白人女性及其伴侣来寻求生育治疗。为什么我们看不到其他背景的患者？这背后有很多历史原因。我认为，不幸的是，妇产科的医疗系统，特别是妇产科，有着相当黑暗的过去，那些非白人、没有钱、没有受过同样教育的女性，曾接受过在许多方面有害的治疗。
And I think there's just a broader mistrust of the medical system in general. I think there is stigma. I don't think I know there's stigma associated with infertility. I think there's less education that goes on to certain patient populations that if we're not going to talk about it, then how do you know that you can even get fertility treatment or know that it's an okay thing to do. Certainly for our LGBTQ patients, there may be concerned that they'll experience harassment or abuse.
我认为人们对整个医疗系统存在更广泛的不信任。我认为存在污名化。我不认为我知道，不孕不育确实存在污名化。我认为对某些患者群体的教育较少，如果我们不谈论它，那么你怎么知道你甚至可以获得生育治疗，或者知道这是一件可以接受的事情。当然，对于我们的LGBTQ患者来说，他们可能会担心会遭遇骚扰或虐待。
There's research that shows in the medical system as many as 2% of LGBTQ patients report being physically harmed by a health care provider. So fear has got to be a driving factor for why patients aren't coming as well. Does discrimination play a role too, have traditionally LGBT individuals wanting to seek out fertility
有研究表明，在医疗系统中，多达2%的LGBTQ患者报告曾受到医疗服务提供者的身体伤害。所以恐惧也一定是患者不来的一个驱动因素。歧视也起作用吗？传统上，LGBT群体想要寻求生育
treatments, have they been maybe not even allowed to come into clinics, or maybe they've been rejected from clinics, or, I mean, has that been something that happens? That's exactly right, yeah. So, historically, only if you were married
治疗时，他们是否可能甚至不被允许进入诊所，或者可能被诊所拒绝，或者，我的意思是，这是否是发生过的事情？完全正确，是的。所以，从历史上看，只有当你结婚时，
would many clinics allow you to come in and do fertility treatment. So single women, single men, same-sex couples, transgender patients, wouldn't be able to even make it through the clinic's doors of whatever clinic that's close to you. And that has changed over time. I will say that unfortunately there still are some clinics out there in the U.S. that will still discriminate against single women, transgender patients, same-sex couples, and so on.
许多诊所才会允许你进入并进行生育治疗。所以单身女性、单身男性、同性伴侣、跨性别患者，甚至无法走进离你最近的诊所的大门。这种情况随着时间的推移已经发生了变化。我必须说，不幸的是，在美国仍然有一些诊所会歧视单身女性、跨性别患者、同性伴侣等等。
So how do we bring them in, do you think? I mean, if we know that just by stats that these individuals also have problems conceiving, how do we get the message out to them that their options and that they're, welcome. So one of the biggest ways that I think about is actually through OBGYNs, which may sound a little different, but that's who women primarily get their education from about their fertility. And sometimes OBGYNs don't bring it up, so we need to educate OBGYNs to bring up the topic a bit more, ask someone if they're struggling to concede. But also for us as women to be empowered to ask, I also think it'd be great if, you know, women,
那么你认为我们该如何吸引他们呢？我的意思是，如果我们从统计数据中知道这些人也有受孕问题，我们该如何向他们传达信息，让他们知道他们有选择，并且他们是受欢迎的？我认为最主要的方式之一其实是通过妇产科医生，这听起来可能有点不同，但女性主要是从他们那里获得关于生育的教育。有时妇产科医生不会主动提起，所以我们需要教育妇产科医生多提一下这个话题，询问某人是否在受孕方面有困难。但也需要我们作为女性有权去询问，我也认为如果女性，
are supposed to go annually for a doctor's appointment. Men don't have that same cultural expectation of going to their doctors. And I think if we talk to men more about their fertility and had urologists or primary care doctors as well on board and asking men and women, regardless of gender identity, regardless of sexual orientation, regardless of whether or not you think they can afford fertility treatment, you bring up the question of, are you struggling?
应该每年进行一次医生预约，那会很棒。男性没有那种去看医生的文化期望。我认为如果我们更多地与男性谈论他们的生育能力，并让泌尿科医生或初级保健医生也参与进来，询问男性和女性，无论性别认同如何，无论性取向如何，无论你是否认为他们负担得起生育治疗，你都提出这个问题：你们在努力吗？
How long has it been taking you to try and get pregnant? Tell me what your hopes and dreams are, and let's see if we can find a way to fulfill them. Do you think some of the stigma around fertility is, because in school we never really talk about it. Like all sucks out, I remember in school, was focused on how not to get pregnant, right? And so I don't think we really talk about what it's like
你们尝试怀孕多久了？告诉我你们的希望和梦想是什么，让我们看看能否找到实现它们的方法。你认为围绕生育的一些污名化是因为在学校里我们从来没有真正谈论过它吗？就像我记得在学校里，重点是如何不怀孕，对吧？所以我认为我们并没有真正谈论过当你试图受孕、当你想要一个家庭时是什么样子，
when you're trying to conceive, when you want to have a family. and what that looks like depending, you know, on what's going on. Do you think that's part of the issue is that we just, like, this is pretty strange that we're talking about it right here, isn't it? It is, it is. And I think you're absolutely right. So we teach people how to not get pregnant. We don't teach them how to get pregnant.
以及根据正在发生的事情，这看起来是什么样的。你认为这是问题的一部分吗？我们只是……我们现在在这里谈论它真的很奇怪，不是吗？确实，确实。而且我认为你说得完全正确。我们教人们如何不怀孕。我们不教他们如何怀孕。
And in fact, we do something even more harmful than that, which is that we lie. And we tell people that it's easy to get pregnant. And it's actually not. So starting at age 20, a 20-year-old woman's perfect chance. of getting pregnant through sex each month is only 25%. That means you have a 75% chance of not getting pregnant each month. But all we're told is that it's easy. All we do is see the easy stories, the whoopses.
事实上，我们做了比那更有害的事情，那就是我们撒谎。我们告诉人们怀孕很容易。但实际上并非如此。从20岁开始，一个20岁女性每个月通过性行为怀孕的完美几率只有25%。这意味着你每个月有75%的几率不会怀孕。但我们被告知的只是它很容易。我们看到的只是那些轻松的故事，那些“意外”。
And of course, no one shares the far more frequent stories of, I got away with it, right? I was drunk in the back of a pickup truck and didn't get pregnant. Nobody shares those stories. And so all we hear and all we see are that it's easy. And then we grow up and we just think, well, you just have sex then, right? Because that's what we're told not to do. So you just have sex.
当然，没有人分享那些更频繁的故事，比如“我侥幸避开了”，对吧？我喝醉了在皮卡车后座上，结果没怀孕。没有人分享这些故事。所以我们听到和看到的都是它很容易。然后我们长大了，就认为，好吧，你只要做爱就行了，对吧？因为那是我们被告知不要做的事情。所以你只要做爱。
No one tells us the time of the month we're supposed to have sex. But you just have sex and then you'll get pregnant and that's not how it works. Right. I'm always amazed when anyone gets pregnant through sex anymore. I'm a little biased working. You might be a little jaded. It might be a little jaded working in a fertility clinic. I know.
没有人告诉我们应该在每月的哪几天做爱。但你只要做爱，然后你就会怀孕，但事实并非如此。没错。我现在对任何通过性行为怀孕的人都感到惊讶。我在工作中有点偏见。你在生育诊所工作可能有点麻木了。我知道。
I might be. But it really is amazing the lack of education just to all of us in the population. But I would say even specifically for mental health professionals and for psychologists, You know, probably most of the audience listening to this and probably most psychologists and mental health professionals in general get no training related to infertility or reproductive loss and how to help their patients who are experiencing these traumatic experiences. I don't know other than the annual ASRM conference, any conference, including APA, that offers that kind of education. So if we're not getting it from our parents, if we're not getting it academically, if we're not getting it in our training as psychologists, we're not getting it from OBGYNs, we're just not going to get it. And we're going to all be left in the dark about how to build families. And maybe then it becomes too late because we think, well, you just keep having sex and then eventually it works.
我可能有点。但对于我们所有人来说，缺乏教育确实令人震惊。但我认为，即使是专门针对心理健康专业人士和心理学家，你知道，可能听这个节目的大多数听众，以及可能大多数心理学家和心理健康专业人士，都没有接受过任何与不孕不育或生殖损失相关的培训，也不知道如何帮助正在经历这些创伤性体验的患者。除了每年的美国生殖医学学会（ASRM）会议外，我不知道还有什么会议，包括美国心理学会（APA）的会议，提供那种教育。所以如果我们没有从父母那里得到，如果我们没有在学术上得到，如果我们没有在心理学家的培训中得到，如果我们没有从妇产科医生那里得到，我们就根本得不到。我们都会对如何建立家庭一无所知。也许到那时就太晚了，因为我们认为，好吧，你只要继续做爱，最终就会成功。
It doesn't always work that way. Right. Well, and I think what I also hear a lot about are the things that are to blame. Yeah. Right? That seems to be one of the favorite. topics is when you're online and you're looking at stories around getting pregnant, it's always, I hear things like, don't do this, don't do that. So let's break some of these down.
事情并不总是那样。没错。好吧，我认为我经常听到的是那些被归咎的原因。是的。对吧？这似乎是最喜欢的话题之一，当你在网上查看关于怀孕的故事时，总是听到类似“别做这个，别做那个”的话。所以让我们来拆解一下这些说法。
Sure. Some of the ones that I've heard about are that are responsible or to blame for infertility, coffee. Sure. No. That's not true. Even when you do IVF, you can have one, you know, not super strong cup of coffee because it's dehydrating, but you can have a cup of coffee a day when you're going through IVF. Okay. Yeah. Alcohol, drinking too much. So alcohol is a little different. You can, you can, according to the research, have, you know, moderate amounts of alcohol. But if you are drinking to excess, it's going to put you at risk of all sorts of problems. And potentially fertility could be one.
当然。我听说过一些被认为是不孕不育的原因，比如咖啡。当然。不。那不是真的。即使你在做IVF，你也可以喝一杯（不是特别浓的）咖啡，因为它会脱水，但你在做IVF时每天可以喝一杯咖啡。好的。是的。酒精，喝太多。所以酒精有点不同。根据研究，你可以喝适量的酒精。但如果你过量饮酒，它会让你面临各种问题的风险。而且生育能力可能就是其中之一。
But yeah, you can have a glass of wine and still get pregnant. And that's not responsible. No, that's not the problem. What about weight gain and weight loss? How does that play into fertility? So BMI matters. If you have... And do people know what BMI is using?
但是，是的，你可以喝一杯葡萄酒，仍然可以怀孕。那不是原因。不，那不是问题所在。体重增加和体重减轻呢？这在生育中起什么作用？所以BMI（身体质量指数）很重要。如果你有……人们知道BMI是什么吗？
So your height and weight ratio predicts all sorts of risks that we might have for our health in general. And so when we weigh too little, as women, we actually can lose our menstrual cycles. That means you're not ovulating. If you're not ovulating an egg, you're not going to get pregnant, right? So weighing too little can weigh into this as well. No pun intended. That was funny. Sorry, laughing at myself.
所以你的身高体重比预测了我们健康方面可能存在的各种风险。所以当我们体重过轻时，作为女性，我们实际上可能会失去月经周期。这意味着你没有排卵。如果你没有排卵，你就不会怀孕，对吧？所以体重过轻也会影响这一点。没有双关语的意思。那很有趣。抱歉，我在自嘲。
And then having a higher weight can be problematic. It's not necessarily going to prevent you from getting pregnant, but it increases the difficulty of getting pregnant and staying pregnant. Like there's an increased risk of miscarriage, early delivery, and things like that. But it doesn't mean that you can't get pregnant. It's just going to be harder. Gotcha. How about diet and exercise?
然后体重过高也可能有问题。它不一定会阻止你怀孕，但它增加了怀孕和维持妊娠的难度。比如流产、早产等风险会增加。但这并不意味着你不能怀孕。只是会更难。明白了。饮食和运动呢？
How does that play into fertility? Like, if I exercise too much, will I not get pregnant? Only if your weight drops so low that you lose your menstrual cycle. But, you know, women can crossfit and get pregnant, right? So it's all about balance. Same thing with diet. There's no fertility food or fertility diet that changes any of this. There's a lot on the Internet about special foods.
这在生育中起什么作用？比如，如果我运动太多，我会不会怀不上？只有当你的体重降得太低以至于失去月经周期时才会。但是，你知道，女性可以做CrossFit（高强度间歇训练）并怀孕，对吧？所以这完全是关于平衡。饮食也是一样。没有所谓的生育食物或生育饮食能改变这一切。互联网上有很多关于特殊食物的信息。
One of the popular ones is blending up and eating the fibrous core of pineapples, which I imagine to be pretty nasty. But it also doesn't change pregnancy outcomes. And the interesting thing about pineapple cores is pineapple cores are hypothesized to not only help get you pregnant, but also cause miscarriages. It can't do both, and it doesn't do either. But those myths are out there as well. There's one really big myth, though. What's that one?
其中一个流行的是把菠萝的纤维芯打碎吃掉，我想那一定很恶心。但它也不会改变怀孕结果。关于菠萝芯有趣的一点是，菠萝芯被假设不仅能帮你怀孕，还会导致流产。它不可能两者都做，而且它两者都不做。但这些迷思确实存在。不过有一个非常大的迷思。那是什么？
The one that really gets my goat. Okay. And that is stress. And that is something that I think all of us here really need to understand how this works. So women are typically blamed. for infertility when it's... That didn't seem to be the theme, right? It always, the theme seemed to be around,
那个真的让我很生气。好的。那就是压力。我认为我们这里的所有人都需要真正理解它是如何运作的。所以女性通常被归咎于不孕不育，当它是……这似乎不是主题，对吧？它总是，主题似乎围绕着，
what is the woman doing or not doing that is causing her to not be able to get pregnant? Right, because, you know, if fertility is easy, which is not, but people think it is, then if it's not easy for you, you just must be messing something up. And if you just fix whatever you're messing up,
女性在做什么或没做什么导致她无法怀孕？没错，因为，你知道，如果生育很容易（其实并不容易），但人们认为它很容易，那么如果这对你来说不容易，你一定是在搞砸什么。如果你修复了你搞砸的任何事情，
then it'll be easy again because fertility's easy. Right. And so... And that's such a dangerous message. It's a horribly dangerous message. It's the largest driver of the distress that we see among our patients that come in for fertility treatment. Distress does not begin when you walk through a fertility clinic's door.
那么它就会再次变得容易，因为生育很容易。没错。所以……那是一个非常危险的信息。这是一个极其危险的信息。这是我们来做生育治疗的患者中压力最大的驱动因素。压力并不是当你走进生育诊所大门时才开始的。
It begins at home when you're trying to get pregnant and it's not working. And the reason why that distress begins is because women tend to blame themselves and everybody else tends to blame them too because this is what we've been doing for generations. We tell women to just relax, which you really have to be careful when you're telling a woman that when she's trying to conceive. But we tell women to just relax because so many of us believe that stress causes infertility or that stress causes miscarriage. And it does not.
它始于你在家尝试怀孕却不成功的时候。压力开始的原因是女性倾向于责怪自己，而其他人也倾向于责怪她们，因为这是我们几代人以来一直在做的事情。我们告诉女性“放松点”，当你告诉一个正在尝试受孕的女性这句话时，你真的必须小心。但我们告诉女性“放松点”，因为我们中有太多人相信压力会导致不孕或流产。但事实并非如此。
We have a plethora of research in multiple areas. We have research on depression and anxiety disorders and time to pregnancy and miscarriage. We have research on stress hormones, particularly cortisol and salivary alpha amylase. We have research on psychotherapy and increasing chances. of pregnancy, which, by the way, if therapy increased chances of pregnancy, we all need to charge a lot more money because we're about to be rich. But none of that research actually shows that stress causes infertility or causes reproductive loss.
我们在多个领域有大量的研究。我们有关于抑郁症、焦虑症与受孕时间及流产的研究。我们有关于压力荷尔蒙，特别是皮质醇和唾液淀粉酶的研究。我们有关于心理治疗和增加怀孕几率的研究，顺便说一句，如果心理治疗能增加怀孕几率，我们都需要收取更多的费用，因为我们很快就会变得富有。但这些研究中没有一项真正表明压力会导致不孕或生殖损失。
There are a bunch of really poorly conducted studies out there, though, that correlate stress levels or cortisol levels and time to conception because we can't conduct a randomized control trial. We can't take a group of women. Stress one of them out. one of them out and see if she gets pregnant versus the one we don't stress out and she gets pregnant. But I think, even though we have all this research and we know that there is absolutely no strong link between stress and infertility, I think the problem with all of these things, whether
不过，外面有一堆非常糟糕的研究，它们将压力水平或皮质醇水平与受孕时间联系起来，因为我们无法进行随机对照试验。我们不能找一组女性，让其中一些人感到压力，看看她是否怀孕，而另一组我们不给压力，看看她是否怀孕。但我认为，尽管我们有所有这些研究，并且我们知道压力与不孕之间绝对没有强有力的联系，但我认为所有这些事情的问题在于，无论是
it's diet, exercise, stress, or even acupuncture is a big one in the world of fertility. But just so you know, we have 16 randomized control trials. We know that acupuncture does not change pregnancy outcomes. But there is a common theme among all these things, and that is control. theoretically I can control my stress so maybe I can get pregnant I can certainly control what I eat so if I do that maybe I can get pregnant I can control what medical care to a degree I seek and so then I'll get pregnant we want to believe that we have control over this because if we don't then what that means is that whether or not we get pregnant and have babies comes down largely to two things that we cannot control one is our biology and the other is faith for anybody
饮食、运动、压力，甚至针灸在生育界也是一个大问题。但你要知道，我们有16项随机对照试验。我们知道针灸不会改变怀孕结果。但所有这些事情都有一个共同的主题，那就是控制。理论上我可以控制我的压力，所以也许我能怀孕；我可以控制我吃什么，所以如果我这样做，也许我能怀孕；我可以控制我寻求的医疗护理程度，所以我就能怀孕。我们想要相信我们对此有控制权，因为如果我们没有，那么这意味着我们是否怀孕并生孩子在很大程度上取决于我们无法控制的两件事：一是我们的生物学，二是信仰（对于任何相信有更高力量可能为他们制定了计划的人来说）。但问题在于，如果是生物学和/或信仰，这意味着生育可能是不公平的。这意味着那些本可以成为出色父母的好人会挣扎。而且外面有很多人，你知道，我们许多人可能认为永远不应该有孩子，那些可能虐待孩子的人。他们可以眨眨眼就生下他们想要的那么多孩子。我们不希望那是真的。
who has belief in a higher power that might have a plan for them. But the problem with that is that if it's biology and or faith, that means that fertility can be unfair. And it means that really good people who would be really amazing parents are going to struggle. And that there's plenty of people out there who, you know, many of us might think should never have kids, people who might abuse kids. And they can blink their eyes and have as many kids as they want. And we don't want that to be true.
所以我们反而会在自己处于低谷时责备自己。我们说这是我们的错，这样我们就可以继续相信我们有控制权。但如果那些东西（压力、饮食或获得昂贵的医疗护理）真的重要，我们早就死了。对吧？早就死了，很久以前就死了。因为我们那点第一世界的经历与生活在第三世界、饥荒肆虐、战火纷飞的国家，每天为生命担忧、零医疗护理的女性相比算不了什么，她们照样怀孕生子。所以我们必须停止兜售那个迷思。我有很多新患者进来告诉我，她们的治疗师、心理学家告诉她们“放松点”，因为压力导致了她们的不孕。
So instead we kick ourselves when we're down. And we say that it's our fault so that we can keep believing that we're in control. But if any of that stuff mattered, stress, diet, or access to fancy medical care, we would be dead. Right? And dead a long time ago dead. Because our little first world experience is nothing compared to women living in third world, famine ravaged, war-torn countries, afraid for their lives every day with zero medical care and they get pregnant and have babies. So we've got to stop selling that myth. And I have so many of my new patients come in and tell me that their therapists, their psychologists, are telling them to just relax because stress is causing their infertility.
我们必须在教育方面做得更好。没错。而且我认为事实和真相的缺失使得其他人可以进来垄断——我想说什么？垄断？谢谢。利用女性对导致不孕原因的恐惧来赚钱，对吧？所以如果我向你推销针灸，对吧，作为一种改变你生育能力的方法，尽管它没有任何效果，那也是其他人利用你的恐惧赚钱的一种方式。所以我认为这既是控制问题，也是一种利用。
We've got to do better at educating. Right. And I think part of the absence of the facts and the truth enables others to come in and monopat—what am I trying to say? Monoplyze? Thank you. To make money off of women's fears about what's causing their infertility, right? So if I sell you acupuncture, right, as this way of changing your fertility, even though it doesn't have any effect on it, that's a way for others to make money off of your fear. So I think it's a control thing and it's also a taking advantage.
这是一个完整的产业。针对一个非常脆弱的群体。我同意。补充剂。我的意思是，你能想到的，外面都有人向你推销，声称能增加你成功的几率。这真的是在利用男性和女性对失去控制的恐惧。这意味着他们可能得不到孩子。但这就是现实。
There's a whole industry. On a really vulnerable population. I agree. Supplements. I mean, you name it, it's out there for what somebody is going to sell you that they say is going to increase your chances of success. And it's really praying on men's and women's fear that they don't have control. And so that means they might not get a baby. But that's the reality of it.
所以男性和女性需要的是强大的情感支持，那些了解真相、了解数据的人，来帮助教育他们，并在他们悲伤的时候提供他们需要的安慰。没错。以便能够继续前进，无论是继续通过他们自己的精子和卵子或身体建立家庭，还是使用第三方生殖技术，也就是捐赠卵子、捐赠精子、代孕等等。所以让我们拆解一下。不孕不育的原因是什么？所以不孕不育的原因通常是
And so what men and women need are they need strong emotional supports who know the truth, who know the data to help educate them and to help provide the comfort they need in their times of grief. Right. To be able to move forward, either with continued family building, you know, with their own sperm and eggs or bodies, or, you know, using third-party reproduction, which is donor eggs, donor sperm, gestational carrier, and so on. So let's break it down. What is the cause of infertility? So the cause of infertility is typically
精子、卵子和子宫内膜。这是你与生俱来的。所以这是你的生物学。这是你的生物学。所以我们每个人出生时都有一套独特的生殖潜能。然后我们长大，爱上我们爱的人，我们将这两套生殖潜能结合在一起。有时它们独立运作，只是不能协同工作，有时其中一方或另一方有一点小问题。但通常是精子和卵子的问题，有时是子宫内膜的问题。但多年来我们只关注卵子和子宫内膜。实际上，直到最近几年，在这一领域，
sperm and eggs and uterine lining. It's what you're born with. So it's your biology. It's your biology. So we're all born with a unique set of reproductive potentials. And then we grow up and we fall in love with whomever we fall in love with and we bring those two sets of reproductive potentials together. And sometimes they work independently and they just don't work together and sometimes there's a little something going on with one or the other of them. But it's typically a sperm and egg problem and sometimes a uterine lining problem. But for years we've only focused on the eggs and the uterine lining. It's actually only been in the last couple of years that in the field,
研究人员才终于关注了精子和男性的年龄。不出所料，我们开始看到精子的重要性，以及与老年男性及其精子相关的问题。所以听起来在某种程度上这也是一种相互作用，对吧？这是我们与生俱来的生物学以及它如何与年龄相互作用。完全正确。所以年龄实际上是第一预测指标，我应该说是卵子的年龄。所使用的卵子有多年轻？
researchers have finally looked at sperm and age of men. And not surprisingly, we're starting to see how important sperm is and the problems associated particularly with older men and their sperm. So it sounds like it's in some ways it's also an interaction, right? It's the biology we're born with and how it interacts with age. That's exactly right. So age is actually the number one predictor, age of the egg, I should say. How young the egg is that's being used?
所以我的卵子可以比我年轻或比我老吗？不，抱歉。好的。所以你的卵子和你的出生日期相同。好的，只是问问。无论你有多健康，或者你感觉有多年轻，看起来有多年轻，这都不重要。谢谢。那是真的。
So can my egg be younger than me or older than me? No, I'm sorry. Okay. So your eggs have your same date of birth. Okay, just questioning. It does not matter how healthy you are or how young you feel and you look young. Thank you. That's true.
但这是，我们的卵子有我们相同的出生日期。而且，我之前提到过，20岁时通过性行为怀孕的完美几率大约是25%。到35岁时，我们每个月通过性行为怀孕的几率是15%。到40岁时，这些几率是个位数。所以你是在告诉我，我处于个位数？我处于零位数。是的，不，它是，所以35岁时，我们的生育能力有明显的下降，但更重要的是，在38岁时，似乎在38岁之后的每两年，女性的生育能力就会下降50%。
But it's, our eggs have our same. date of birth. And, you know, I mentioned earlier that our perfect chances of getting pregnant through sex at age 20 started about 25%. By age 35, we have a 15% chance of getting pregnant each month through sex. And by age 40, those chances are in the single digits. So I'm in the single digits, is what you're telling me. I'm in like the zero digits. Yeah, no, it's, so 35, there's a noticeable decline in our fertility, But more importantly, at 38, it appears that every two years after age 38, there's a 50% drop in women's fertility.
所以到42岁时，我们在诊所看到的绝大多数女性真的非常非常挣扎。到43岁时，我会说，你知道，即使在42岁，我们看到的绝大多数怀孕都可能需要使用捐赠卵子。卵子捐赠者通常是一位20岁出头、愿意分享一些那些20岁卵子的年轻女性。记住，卵子的年龄预测了这一切的走向。所以你可以取一个21岁女性的卵子，用它们制造一个胚胎，然后把它植入一个，你知道，比如55岁，已经绝经的女性体内。
And so by age 42, most of the women that we're seeing in the clinic are really, really struggling. And by age 43, and I would say, you know, even at 42, the majority of the pregnancies that we're going to be seeing are likely to need the use of donor eggs. an egg donor is a young woman typically in her early to mid-20s who's willing to share some of those 20-year-old eggs. Remember, the age of the egg predicts how this goes. And so you can take a 21-year-old's eggs and make an embryo with them and put them in a woman who's, you know, let's say even 55, somebody who's gone through menopause.
而且你有极好的机会让她怀孕并足月生下那个孩子，因为那个卵子非常年轻。好的，那就有好消息了。所以尽管你的生物学和年龄有这种相互作用，使得它更具挑战性，但仍然有怀孕的方法。绝对有怀孕的方法。或者拥有一个家庭。
And you have an amazing chance of getting her pregnant and having that baby carried a term because of how young that egg was. Okay, so there are good news then. So even though your biology and your age have this interaction effect that makes it more challenging, there are still ways to get pregnant. There absolutely are ways to get pregnant. Or to have a family.
拥有一个家庭，没错。对吧？所以我对每个人都这么说。没有人因为精子、卵子或身体的原因而必须停止成为父母。通往为人父母的道路可能会有变化，并且可能会有一些与
And to have a family, true. Right. So that's exactly what I say. So I say to everybody, nobody's sperm or eggs or bodies ever had to stop them from being a parent. There may be changes in the path to parenthood, and there may be some grieving associated
通往为人父母的道路相关的悲伤。所以如果你不能使用你自己的精子或卵子，或身体，你可能会为此感到悲伤，并以相当情绪化的方式悲伤。但这并不意味着你不能成为父母。这确实意味着你将不得不考虑进行一些额外的对话。比如如果你与代孕者、卵子捐赠者或精子捐赠者合作，你将不得不考虑，特别是对于精子和卵子捐赠者，在某个时候与你未来的
with the path to parenthood. So if you're not able to use your own sperm or eggs, or body, you're probably going to grieve that and grieve that in a fairly emotional way. But it doesn't mean that you can't be a parent. It does mean that there's going to be some additional conversations that you're going to have to think about having. Like if you work with a gestational carrier or an egg donor or sperm donor, you're going to have to think about, particularly with sperm and egg donors, at some point talking to your future
孩子谈论他们是如何受孕的，我知道这对父母来说是非常令人焦虑的事情。但研究表明，当我们对孩子诚实时，这是一种“尽早且频繁”披露使用他人DNA受孕的方法。就像领养一样，孩子们通常表现得很好。而且就像领养一样，我们看到的那些糟糕的故事，我们一直在社交媒体上看到它们，
children about how they were conceived, which I know is something that's really anxiety-provoking for parents. but the research shows that when we are honest with kids, it's sort of this early and often approach of disclosing conception using someone else's DNA. Just like with adoption, kids generally do well. And just like with adoption, the bad stories we see, and we're seeing them all the time in social media,
都是那些被欺骗了一辈子的孩子，然后可能一位父母去世了，幸存的父母告诉了他们，或者他们在遗嘱中得知了。或者通过23andMe和Ancestry.com。如今，采集口腔拭子并寄出是如此容易，大约一个月后，你就能看到所有与你有基因关联的人，关联程度如何，如果你得知你与你认为应该有基因关联的人并没有基因关联，那将是一个多么大的惊喜和背叛。
are kids who've been lied to for their whole lives, and then maybe a parent dies and the surviving parent tells them, or they learn about it in a will. Or 23andMe and Ancestry.com. It is so easy nowadays to swab your cheeks, send it in, and about a month later, you get to see all the people to whom you're genetically related and to what degree and what a surprise and a betrayal it might be if you learn you're not genetically related to who you think you're supposed to be genetically related to.
所以，再次作为心理健康专业人士，这是我们绝对会越来越多地看到的事情。孩子们在年龄较大时才得知真相，因为他们的父母没有告诉他们。他们把它当作一个秘密，然后我们必须能够为那些患者或客户提供有效的咨询，关于应对、沟通策略等等。所以我认为这也会是你诊所工作的一部分，正如你之前提到的，压力不会导致不孕，但有受孕问题
And so, again, as mental health professionals, that is something that we are absolutely going to see more and more. Kids who are learning at older ages because their parents didn't tell them. They kept it a secret. it, and then we've got to be able to provide effective counseling to those patients or clients about coping, communication strategies, et cetera. So I would think that this would also be part of your job then in the clinic, is if you mentioned earlier, that stress doesn't cause infertility, but having problems conceiving
本身就是有压力的。完全正确。对吧？所以你的角色是帮助人们管理那种压力。我想你谈到了一些关于建立支持和情感支持的内容。而且我认为还要讨论有哪些资源可以帮助你引导这些对话？因为我想这不仅仅是与你拥有的孩子进行对话，可能还有你的家人。因为我认为我们的家庭对于建立一个家庭的样子可能有非常、也许是传统的想法。
is stressful. That's exactly right. Right? So your role is to help people manage that stress. I think you talked a little bit about building supports and emotional supports. And then I would think also having discussions about what are the resources to help you navigate these conversations? Because I imagine it's not even just conversations with the children that you have, but probably your families too. Because I think our families have very, maybe traditional ideas about what it looks like to make a family.
完全正确。而且，你知道，各种宗教机构也有很多宗教信仰，这让患者担心他们是否在做正确的事情。如果他们的父母持有相同的宗教信仰，我该如何与我的父母分享？如果他们有与我不同的信仰，我该如何获得我可能需要的支持？我会说的是，想到这一点让我发笑，但，你知道，有很多非常可爱的儿童绘本是关于建立你的家庭的，关于通过捐赠卵子建立你的家庭，关于通过捐赠精子建立你的家庭，关于通过领养、IVF建立你的家庭，无论它是什么。
That's exactly right. And, you know, there's also a lot of religious beliefs for various religious institutions that make patients concerned about whether or not they're doing the right thing. And if their parents hold those same religious affiliations, how am I going to share that to my parents? How am I going to get the support that I might need? If they have different beliefs than I might have, what I would say is, and I, it makes me laugh to think about this, but, you know, there's a lot of really cute children's picture books about building your family, about building your family through donor egg, about building your family through donor sperm, about building your family through adoption, IVF, whatever it might be.
确实如此。而且，你知道，各种宗教机构也有许多宗教信仰，这让患者担心自己所做的是否正确。如果他们的父母也持有同样的宗教信仰，我该如何告诉父母呢？我该如何获得我可能需要的支持呢？如果他们的信仰与我不同，我会说——想到这一点我就觉得好笑——你知道，有很多非常可爱的儿童绘本是关于组建家庭的，关于通过捐赠卵子组建家庭，关于通过捐赠精子组建家庭，关于通过收养、试管婴儿或任何其他方式组建家庭。
And we explain things to children in ways that anyone could understand. Sure. So when my patients talk about not being sure how to educate their parents about all of this, I say to them, why don't you send some of the parents, the future grandparents, some of these kids' books? Because they can learn in the same way that you're going to start talking to your five-year-old about when they ask you, where did I come from? Right. And then everybody can get on the same page with how to understand that. There's also a lot of resources online.
我们用任何人都能听懂的方式向孩子们解释这些事情。当然。所以当我的患者说不知道该如何向父母解释这一切时，我会对他们说，为什么不给父母——也就是未来的祖父母——寄一些这样的儿童读物呢？因为他们可以像你教五岁孩子回答“我从哪里来”这个问题时那样去学习。没错。这样大家就能在如何理解这件事上达成共识。网上也有很多资源。
So resolve.org is the National Fertility Association. Okay.resolve.org. Resolve. Resolve, yeah. R-E-E-S-O-R-E-S-O-G. It's a great place to get education about support groups that are close to you throughout the U.S., about the financial grants that are available, about the research on fertility. It's just a great resource for education,
Resolve.org 是美国国家生育协会。好的，resolve.org。Resolve。R-E-S-O-L-V-E。这是一个获取教育信息的好地方，可以了解你附近的互助小组、可申请的经济补助，以及关于生育的研究。它是一个非常好的教育资源平台。
and so you can redirect friends and family members, or just yourself as a patient, can go and look at that information as well. And there are also a lot of us, not a ton, but there's a lot of us who have been trained, mental health professionals in the U.S. and around the world, with a subspecialty in reproductive medicine, and so looking for someone who actually has the appropriate specialty. That specialization, yeah.
你可以把这些信息转发给朋友和家人，或者作为患者，你自己也可以去查看。此外，我们中还有很多人——虽然不是特别多，但也有不少——是受过专业训练的心理健康专家，遍布美国和世界各地，专门从事生殖医学领域的研究。所以，寻找真正具备相关专业资质的人很重要。那种专业化，没错。
Yeah, I think that's a really important message. Where do you find them, though? So the largest group is called the MHPG. It's the Mental Health Professional Group of the American Society for Reproductive Medicine. You can actually go online to the ASRM.org website, and it'll have this sort of find a member link. Oh, okay. You could also just reach out to your local fertility clinic, and even if you're not a patient there and say, hey, you know, I'm really having a hard time coping with trying to build my family. who do you work with?
是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的信息。但去哪里找他们呢？最大的组织叫 MHPG，即美国生殖医学学会下的心理健康专业小组。你可以登录 ASRM.org 网站，上面有一个“寻找会员”的链接。哦，好的。你也可以直接联系当地的生育诊所，即使你不是那里的患者，也可以问：“嘿，我在努力组建家庭的过程中感到非常痛苦，你们通常和谁合作？”
Because most fertility clinics actually don't have psychology embedded in them, even though I think they should. That's a whole other podcast. But call them up and they will have mental health professionals with whom they have a relationship and you can get redirected there as well. So I would think that things have changed a lot in the last 25 years in terms of how we think about reproduction, how we think about fertility. Probably success rates of IVF have probably increased.
因为大多数生育诊所实际上并没有配备心理咨询服务，尽管我认为他们应该有。那是另一个话题了。但你可以打电话给他们，他们会有合作的心理健康专家，你也可以被转介到那里。我认为在过去 25 年里，我们对生殖和生育的看法已经发生了很大变化。试管婴儿（IVF）的成功率可能也提高了。
Where do you see things going? What does the future look like when we're thinking about fertility and infertility and how we create families? So I can tell you what I hope it looks like and also what I think some of the emerging technologies might be. So what I hope is that someday we have a federal mandate for coverage for fertility treatment. so that every patient, every individual who is struggling to build their family can get the support they need to be able to have kids.
你认为未来会怎样？当我们思考生育、不孕不育以及如何组建家庭时，未来是什么样的？我可以告诉你我希望它是什么样，以及我认为可能会出现的一些新兴技术。我希望有一天我们能有联邦强制的生育治疗保险覆盖，这样每一位努力组建家庭的患者、每一个人都能获得他们所需的经济支持，从而能够拥有孩子。
And I also want to say that you don't have to have children too. Being child free is a perfectly lovely choice, but for those who do want children to have that financial support there through insurance, I think would be amazing. In terms of what it's likely to look like from a medical perspective, there's some really interesting and ethically complex research that's going on. I mean, everything that we do is ethically complex in the world of reproduction. But, you know, some of the emerging technologies that will have those complexities, one is CRISPR. So the big articles that came out about the use of CRISPR outside of what seems to be appropriate research protocols and caution in the way that it was used. But CRISPR has the potential to help us in the future alter embryos, so fertilized eggs, alter embryos to reduce the risk of certain diseases. Now we can already reduce the risk of certain diseases with genetic testing of embryos, but this is this is, this is.
我也想说，你也可以选择不要孩子。不生孩子是一个非常好的选择，但对于那些想要孩子的人来说，如果能通过保险获得经济支持，那将是非常棒的。从医学角度来看，目前正在进行一些非常有趣且在伦理上很复杂的研究。我的意思是，在生殖领域，我们所做的一切在伦理上都是复杂的。但你知道，一些即将出现的技术会带来这些复杂性，其中之一就是 CRISPR。关于在似乎不符合适当研究方案的情况下使用 CRISPR 的报道引起了很大争议。但 CRISPR 未来有可能帮助我们改变胚胎，即受精卵，以降低某些疾病的风险。现在我们已经可以通过胚胎基因检测来降低某些疾病的风险，但这是一种……
a slightly different way of doing that. So that's one. I do think CRISPR is probably going to become a bigger technology. The other one that is, I think, really cool, especially for our LGBT patients is a new technology that's also getting some press. It's not available for any of us to use. Let me just put that out there. Is that they are doing some research to take our own individual stem cells and be able to
这是一种略有不同的方法。所以这是其一。我认为 CRISPR 可能会成为一项更重要的技术。另一项我认为非常酷的技术，特别是对我们的 LGBT 患者而言，是一项正在受到媒体关注的新技术。它目前还不供我们使用，我先声明这一点。他们正在进行一些研究，试图提取我们个人的干细胞，并能够
turn them into sperm and eggs, sperm and eggs. So that means I could make sperm as a woman. You could make sperm as well that individuals assigned male at birth could make eggs. And so, for example, with our same-sex couples who end up usually needing to use a sperm donor or an egg donor, instead, if they could each make sperm or eggs, then they could both be genetically related to their children if they wanted to be. Right. Sounds pretty futuristic.
将它们转化为精子和卵子。这意味着作为女性，我可以制造精子。你也可以制造精子，而出生时被指定为男性的人也可以制造卵子。例如，对于我们的同性伴侣，他们通常需要使用精子捐赠者或卵子捐赠者，如果他们每个人都能制造精子或卵子，那么如果他们愿意，他们都可以与孩子在基因上建立联系。没错。听起来很科幻。
It does. It does, but I think it holds a lot of promise for family building and also for women who, you know, go through cancer treatment and weren't able to freeze their eggs before chemotherapy destroyed their fertility, that, you know, maybe it holds even the possibility of being able to help women who've run out of eggs to be able to make new eggs and build their families if they want to. Well, sounds like there's a lot on the horizon. A lot has happened. I think my takeaways are probably. thinking about how we need to have more dialogue around this. We need more education and resources. We need to stop blaming women. Please, let's stop blaming women. Don't blame men either, but let's just stop blaming women.
确实如此。但我认为它在家庭组建方面非常有前景，对于那些接受过癌症治疗，在化疗破坏生育能力之前没能冷冻卵子的女性来说，它甚至可能为那些卵子耗尽的女性提供制造新卵子并组建家庭的可能性。听起来前景广阔。发生了很多变化。我想我的收获可能是：我们需要围绕这个话题进行更多的对话。我们需要更多的教育和资源。我们需要停止指责女性。拜托，让我们停止指责女性。也不要指责男性，但让我们停止指责女性吧。
Let's not blame anybody. No, let's not blame anyone. But that there are a lot of opportunities and hope, I think, for creating families into multiple different ways and or thinking about what life might look like, and you as the psychologist can be there to help. Yeah, I love what I do. I can tell. I love what you do too.
让我们不要指责任何人。不，让我们不要指责任何人。但我想，通过多种不同方式组建家庭，或者思考生活可能的样子，有很多机会和希望，而你作为心理学家可以在那里提供帮助。是的，我热爱我的工作。看得出来。我也热爱你的工作。
Thank you. Thank you. So I want to thank Dr. Lawson for being here today and joining us and really opening up this dialogue and sharing your expertise. If you liked what you heard today and you want to send us an email, you can email at us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. If you'd like to hear more of our podcast episodes, you can find them on iTunes or Stitcher or really anywhere that you find your podcasts. They're also available on our website at www. of Speaking of Psychology.org. I'm Dr. Vale Wright. It's been a pleasure to be your guest host today. I really appreciate everybody listening and take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。谢谢。所以我要感谢 Lawson 博士今天来到这里，加入我们，真正开启了这场对话并分享了你的专业知识。如果你喜欢今天的内容并想给我们发邮件，你可以发送至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。如果你想收听我们更多的播客节目，可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何你收听播客的地方找到它们。它们也可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到。我是 Vale Wright 博士。今天能担任客座主持人是我的荣幸。非常感谢大家的收听，保重。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。